welcome to this video playing
grandmaster moy anguish we don't know
his real name but it's a night off g6
against this okay and that couple of
possible setups here one is this can
cancel short and long both this quite
feasible I'm going for long just more
interesting so what are you saying
you're saying that you find this rubbish
I know I'm playing as quickly as as the
people are always criticize but this
just looks bad for black so let's play a
quick move and see what happens so will
not be 3 or what do we do that f3 also
looks good this this whole pollution
looks weird let's do this attending 95
also
okay did not really have that on the
radar all that much which probably
sounds weird because a section normal
move out but still
write a three I can probably just go to
anyone this yeah I've 95 but he's got
this Queen B 5 move that is annoying
probably more than annoying and
threatening to win the Queen enter and
made it was not buy original intention a
bishop before but okay
yeah he wants to sacrifice something
here on b2 or something like that okay
let's just let's just fire away they're
not think too much
but this show already misses something
before because I cannot believe in this
even a little bit for black this night
we aid and stuff that can never be good
but let's see I Scott Bishop g6 now
last night a three all the time and
those damn sacrifice on c3 and while I
3a threaten night is 60 it's not that
easy to do just like that so 96 doesn't
do anything wrong maybe it doesn't 96
all kinds of mayhem okay check all kinds
of me dancin it's just not not that
threatening if I take on a fade his
counter threats their time morning
probably much more dangerous which one
cannot take 95 I don't know after gamble
now here I cannot calculate this anyway
[Music]
with 40 seconds or what whatever I have
him you can probably just take the one
Queen f6 was my idea threatening 97 made
and Queen g7 mate
maybe he can play Bishop takes you to or
simply I it's not so easy Bishop takes
King a one Bishop team on the screen to
screen g5 mate made it to maybe
something crazy this one okay so Queen
f6 what's happening there Queen B 5
check it's the thing now that is
actually winning okay what a shame
you can probably take you six by the way
this is not made then yeah thats it's
actually pretty simple you can just take
my 69
and fortunately 25 is again a threat
check check okay white present yeah I
know we can see how like you could have
been punished for all that so let's see
how I mean like here this I cannot
believe it overnight a 5v5 98 that's not
going to work but they're doing it in
glitz there's another matter this is
already bad due to the exchange psych it
seems so this was right so this and then
we should be four or something when yes
no this piece is don't play that this
can never be okay it just always going
to be murky with this little time
involved if you t check and probably
just better like that yeah yeah so I
have to do this then okay he has to a
sec the exchange to to have some kind of
idea at least and this is playing with
all those pieces him that it's just bad
the end this this God knowing this is
probably too lame should be four instead
I could have taken on bit already but
should be six and now I just fired with
with f5 which is the switches which does
not work but what was funny at least
yeah so 95 actually winds jeggings if i
play it immediately oh oh my god ok now
I'm threatening night at weenie of 697
maybe it is not win i mean the engines
depth is not great i should switch this
on
Wow
you
q yeah evaluation is rising probably why
this winning would carry this is just
like just you just fire away whatever
check nice chat system another after I
have to play this is one of those things
where you have to be extremely precise
at the beginning like here 9 p-3 is just
important also better to have this
diagonal open you have to basically kill
this off quickly I mean not like winning
in terms of clings upward playing in a
way that is not getting out of this
simply and here this this role just
loose this is awful anyway thanks for
watching